hey
hi how are you
yeah good how are you doing today i am
doing well i appreciate you talking to
me about this i love the addams family i
loved the old tv show i loved the live
action movies i have so much fun with
these animated movies
and i'm curious how do you channel your
inner wednesday is there anything you do
to immediately get back into her voice
and her mindset
yeah you know i think the biggest thing
is is just trying to really figure out
her intonation and her her kind of
vocality on vowels you know i think
something that i really found in the
first movie that surprised all of us
was
her strange pronunciations of words you
know like cell phone and like how she's
never probably said those things before
so i really try to focus on that and
kind of get into the space where she's
still observing and understanding and
you know coming into the 21st century
almost you know she's like pull it out
of the 1700s and like put into the 21st
century almost you know
when you voice her do you do anything to
get into character i mean even though
this is animated and we don't see you do
you dress a particular way or do you
change your physicality when you're
voicing her
yeah i mean i think
i think uh you know they always record
us while we're while we're uh
doing our our voices because they
actually map it into the animation a lot
of times what we do with our faces so i
i'd love to see those recordings because
i do get really into it 100 like you you
know you start to kind of like do little
things like her and like do her weird
little like
things with her face and so 100 you know
i think you have to get into it you have
to physically get into it because um if
you don't it just sounds flat you know
what i mean i think when we speak in
real life we're very animated you know a
little bit of a little i guess there's a
pun there somewhere
but so when you're doing animation you
have to be as animated as you are in
real life if not more so um so trying to
up the ante will also play a character
that's predominantly monotone um so
trying to to you know walk that walk
that tightrope
even though the adams family are so well
known and so iconic as characters this
version feels a bit different
so what do you like about her look and
her personality and this specific
wednesday
yeah you know that was something that
was really fun at the start of this is i
think we all really wanted to
[Music]
shirk the different types of atoms that
come before us and really start to add a
new flavor to it and that was something
that i i was kind of told by them early
on i was like how far can i go with my
own kind of take on wednesday and they
were basically like run with it you know
go for it and see where that lives with
you um and so i really tried to find my
own wednesday and and uh and and find
something different for audiences
because that's something i really love
watching remakes and stuff like that is
when people do
have their own take on the character um
and and their own kind of pace on the
characters so that was something that we
we really wanted to modernize and see
what that looks like taking the the girl
from from the the time period and
putting her into a more modern outlook
and how much she also feels like a fish
out of water within that wednesday has a
bit of an identity crisis in this film a
little bit
did seeing her try to fit into another
family just really sort of helps
solidify why she belongs in the addams
family for you oh for sure i mean her
with the turtleneck and lab coat like no
way that is not wednesday adams um you
know and then her calling morticia
morticia instead of mother i was just
like ah no
like don't do it um but 100 you know i
think she is
even if she wasn't blood related she
isn't adam's no matter what you know i
think that's something that i really
love about this story as well is is the
idea of chosen family and how even at
the end of it she chooses to be an adams
no matter what even though she isn't
adam's
what are you most enjoying about the
process of doing voiceover work does it
feel different when you're voicing a
famous character instead of just an
animal that you couldn't be in real life
oh 100 you know you really you really
want to kind of what we were saying
before you want to get into the
physicality i think when you're being a
person um and you really want to try and
personify them in a way where they feel
human you know they feel like they can
walk off the screen and and i think when
you really get into the sweet spot of
that that's when you you get to watch
the film and you feel moved and you feel
you know really kind of awestruck by the
emotion and then this one for sure like
i i definitely teared up at the end i
was like
like i i was really moved by this by
this uh by this take on this film
do you know what's next for you as far
as live action and us getting to see you
in your form
yes yeah um i i have mother android
coming out uh here on december uh 17th
so i'll be uh releasing a bunch of stuff
on that pretty soon and then currently
i'm filming a show for amazon um by the
creators of jonah uh nolan and lisa joy
um called the peripheral
and that's kind of sci-fi too right i
mean it sort of falls
into that whole category what what
yeah what attracted you to that project
and how
what kind of take on sci-fi is it i mean
i think william gibson is such a great
writer um and i've always been
interested in his writing so it's a
wonderful book
um and then bringing that into the the
the atmosphere of you know jonah and
lisa who over at kilter they're
producing this and you know i've i've
always loved
his take on on projects i've always
loved her take on projects and i think
they're really brilliant and they put
together a really wonderful
casting proof for this and a great show
runner so you know it's my first foray
into tv um and and i cannot wait for
people to see
um their take on this story and you know
it really deals with pretty
honestly with with pretty realistic
ideals to what we're going through
currently in the world and to the point
of where when we're filming this we're
kind of like oh
are we actually
not in a dystopian future but we're just
in a documentary about ourselves
so it's been fun it's been mind-boggling
it's been tricky it's been fun and i
think people are gonna have their you
know their their their socks blown off a
little bit by this one it's uh
it's tricky it's tricky
well awesome thank you for talking to me
about that and all things adam's family
i appreciate it
of course enjoy your day talk to you
later
you